Unsere besten klassischen Supercomputer werden immer leistungsfähiger,
und wir werden immer besser im Rechnen, einschließlich der Simulation von Systemen.
Aber die Simulation der Natur ist generell ein sehr schwieriges Problem.
Mein Name ist Victoria Lipinska und heute werden wir einen der Algorithmen erkunden,
der die Simulation der Natur auf einem Quantencomputer möglich machen könnte.
Fangen wir mit einem Beispiel an und betrachten Koffein.
Es ist ein einfaches Molekül.
Um die Energiekonfiguration nur eines einzigen Koffeinmoleküls darzustellen,
bräuchten wir ungefähr zehn hoch 48 Bits.
Das ist eine Zehn mit 48 Nullen
und entspricht etwa 10 % der Anzahl der Atome auf der Erde.
Und es wird sogar noch schlimmer.
Wenn du 125 Orbitale hast und alle möglichen
Konfigurationen speichern möchtest, brauchst du mehr Speicher,
als dein klassischer Computer Atome im Universum hat.
Das lässt sich mit Supercomputern unmöglich darstellen.
Es gibt jedoch Hoffnung für Quantencomputer,
weil sie von Natur aus gut darin sind, die Natur zu simulieren.
Für ein Koffeinmolekül würde das bedeuten, das System
mit 160 qubits darzustellen.
Das klingt schon viel handhabbarer.
Es wurden verschiedene Quantenalgorithmen vorgeschlagen, die es
kleineren Quantencomputern ermöglichen, die Natur heuristisch zu simulieren.
Bühne frei für: den variationalen Quanteneigenwert-Löser, kurz VQE.
VQE ist ein Algorithmus, der teils auf einem Quanten-
computer und teils auf einem klassischen Computer läuft.
Er ermöglicht es uns, Werte zu finden, die ein gegebenes Optimierungsproblem lösen.
VQE ist eng verwandt mit anderen Methoden, die
Parameter variieren, wie dem quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Anwendungen von VQE in deiner Branche oder Forschung zu identifizieren
ist eine gewisse Kunst, aber es gibt grobe Leitlinien.
Generell ist VQE auf Probleme anwendbar, die sich
als Optimierungsproblem mit kontinuierlichen Variablen formulieren lassen.
Das ist zum Beispiel in weiten Teilen der Quantenchemie der Fall.
In der Chemie interessieren wir uns sehr oft für den Grundzustand.
Der Grundzustand ist der Zustand mit der niedrigsten Energie des Systems.
Um die Grundzustandsenergie zu finden, erkundet VQE
die Energie für verschiedene Konfigurationen des Systems
und sucht nach der Konfiguration mit der niedrigsten Energie.
Auf hoher Ebene nimmt VQE eine Beschreibung des Quantensystems entgegen
und sucht nach der niedrigsten Energie.
Das macht er, indem er die Konfiguration des Systems variiert.
und nach der niedrigsten Energie sucht.
Zu Beginn müssen wir eine geeignete Beschreibung des Systems eingeben,
die der Quantencomputer versteht, sowie einen Satz von Parametern, die es beschreiben
und optimiert werden.
Der Quantenteil des
Algorithmus bereitet das System in einem Zustand vor,
der durch einen gegebenen Parametersatz beschrieben wird, und berechnet die Energie.
Während der klassische Teil dafür zuständig ist,
diese Parameter bei jedem Schritt zu optimieren.
Dieser quanten-klassische Prozess wird wiederholt,
bis wir die niedrigste Energie erreichen.
Schauen wir uns jetzt genauer an, was unter der Haube passiert.
Die Energiekonfiguration wird typischerweise im Hamiltonian beschrieben,
und das ist in der Regel eine sehr große Matrix.
In der Algebra würde man, um den kleinsten Eigenwert der Matrix zu finden,
der der niedrigsten Energie des Systems entspricht,
einfach eine Singulärwertzerlegung durchführen.
Die Matrizen, mit denen wir es zu tun haben, sind jedoch exponentiell groß,
und es ist ein exponentiell schwieriges Problem, dies algebraisch zu tun.
Dieser Hamiltonian muss in einer Form dargestellt werden,
die der Quantencomputer versteht.
Also übersetzt aus der Chemiesprache in die Quantencomputing-Sprache.
Keine Sorge wegen der Details.
Es gibt letztlich programmierbare Wege, den Hamiltonian, wie er
in der Chemie vorkommt, in einen für einen Quantencomputer verständlichen Hamiltonian umzuwandeln.
Wir geben dann diesen
Hamiltonian zusammen mit dem circuit ein, den wir als Variationsform bezeichnen.
Die Wahl einer Variationsform ist eine gewisse Kunst.
Nochmal:
Sie stellt unsere beste Vermutung dar, wie der Quantenzustand des Systems aussehen könnte.
Dieser variationelle circuit ist mit einem Parametersatz Theta parametrisiert,
und wir geben auch eine anfängliche Wahl dieser Parameter ein.
Darauf aufbauend führt der Quantenteil von VQE folgendes durch:
Er bereitet den Referenzzustand vor, zum Beispiel den Nullzustand;
verwendet einen parametrisierten quantum circuit, die Variationsform, um einen Quanten-
zustand für eine anfängliche Parameterschätzung auf dem Quantencomputer vorzubereiten; und er schätzt
die Energie, die dem über den Hamiltonian ausgewerteten Zustand entspricht.
Diese Energieschätzung wird dann weitergegeben
an den klassischen Optimierer, der einen neuen Parametersatz findet.
Die Parameter gelangen wieder zurück zum Quantenlöser,
und der gesamte Prozess wird wiederholt.
Der Quantencomputer findet eine neue Energieschätzung, der
klassische Optimierer findet einen neuen Parametersatz, und so weiter.
Wir wiederholen diesen Prozess, bis die Lösung konvergiert.
Das bedeutet, bis der Unterschied zwischen den Ergebnissen aufeinanderfolgender Schritte klein genug ist,
für unsere Zwecke.
Am Ende gibt der Algorithmus diese minimierte Energie zurück.
Okay, das ist großartig.
Aber vielleicht fragst du dich, woher wir wissen, dass das wirklich funktioniert
und dass wir nicht versehentlich eine Energie finden, die niedriger ist als die gesuchte?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Es stellt sich heraus, dass wir niemals eine niedrigere Energie schätzen können.
Das verdanken wir dem sogenannten Variationsprinzip.
Das Variationsprinzip besagt, dass die größte untere
Schranke der Energie des Systems immer dessen
niedrigste Energie ist, die dem Grundzustand entspricht.
Das bedeutet, dass die Energie, die für jeden anderen Zustand des Systems ausgewertet wird,
immer größer als die niedrigste Energie ist.
Daher können wir mit VQE niemals etwas erhalten,
das unter der Grundzustandsenergie liegt.
Wir können jedoch tatsächlich zu etwas konvergieren,
das größer als das gesuchte Minimum ist.
Das wird oft als metastabile Lösung bezeichnet,
und es ist eine Herausforderung, an der Forscher täglich arbeiten.
VQE ist nützlich, weil es flachere circuits verwendet
als andere Verfahren, die uns die Schätzung der Grundzustandsenergie ermöglichen.
Das macht es geeignet für kurzfristige Quantenhardware.
In diesem Video haben wir einen Einblick bekommen, was VQE kann und wie er aufgebaut ist.
Ich ermutige dich aber, Qiskit in diesem Kontext zu erkunden.
Auch wenn wir uns noch am Anfang unserer Quantenreise befinden,
könnte es für Probleme, die du zu lösen versuchst, bereits nützlich sein.
Mein Name ist Victoria Lipinska und das war ein Überblick
über den variationalen Quanteneigenwert-Löser-Algorithmus.